You got wrinkles on your forehead like this.
Put this skin tiny beef tallow all over your wrinkles.
You got small lines right here.
The skin tiny beef tallow all over your mouth.
If you got crinkly eyes like this when you smile,
put the skin tiny beef tallow right near your eyes.
I've been using skin China Beef tallow
and it made my skin glow like crazy.
Like this is the best my skin has looked in my entire life.
This is the first beef tallow to have anti aging properties.
It has chamomile mushroom extract and shea butter
that keeps the skin super hydrated.
It makes it super bouncy and elastic like this.
All kinds of nutrients in here,
antioxidant properties.
And this stuff is 100% grass fed organic beef tallow.
No harsh ingredients. There's no BS inside of here.
It's a bunch of natural ingredients that go straight into the skin
to make it look really youthful.
If you want to get that youthful, glowy skin,
you should definitely start using this stuff.
I'll leave a link on the bottom left with the orange cart.
Just act fast
because a lot of people are buying this with the huge sale
and they will go out of stock soon.